viewers of the show sometimes write to
me they say David love what you're doing
love independent media corporate media
totally failed us during the 2016
election but I can't really support you
with money so what else can I do to help
the show and really any involvement that
you can have with show is useful on any
of our social media platforms of course
run facebook at facebook.com slash david
pakman show we have an awesome reddit
discussion forum where you can actually
discuss the show stories suggest story
suggests interview ideas cetera at david
pakman.com slash reddit re d di t and
you can subscribe for free there you can
follow me on twitter at d pakman you can
follow the show on twitter at david
pakman show and i hope that at minimum
you're subscribed on our youtube channel
which is rapidly heading towards 300,000
subscribers if you haven't yet
subscribed at youtube.com slash the
David Pakman show please do and the
other thing is we happen right now to
also be in the middle of an indy gogo
fundraiser to expand the show so if
three or six dollars a month is a bit
much for you as part of membership you
can donate even just a dollar or two to
the indiegogo campaign that we have it
david pakman.com slash donate and i know
people sometimes say what's the point of
even going to that website and donating
if i can only donate a dollar or two but
every single donation actually does help
even if you don't think it gets us much
closer to the financial goal every time
that we have an additional donor that
helps our fundraiser be optimized in the
indiegogo algorithm so don't let the
reality that you might only be donating
a couple of bucks stop you every single
donation matters and counts and lastly
if you ever shop at amazon.com the money
you already spend on amazon you can take
seven or eight percent of that and send
it back to us if before shopping you go
to david pakman.com slash amazon so many
ways to support the show without
spending any money at all and of course
even just subscribing on youtube really
helps and goes a long way and i
appreciate everybody who is in some way
involved with any of our
networks and distribution platforms